the 31 page indictment alleges mana fort
and gates acted as unregistered agents
of the Ukrainian government and
political parties they're accused of
funneling 75 million dollars to multiple
shell companies in the United States and
overseas mana for allegedly laundered
more than 18 million dollars to pay for
property renovations landscaping along
with cars and clothing CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clayman is here to explain
how prosecutors are using the money
laundering charges to build their case
Ricky good morning morning I mean all
you have to do is read through this and
boy it's detailed at every little
payment to every landscaper and where it
went through the money why our
transports how do you build a case like
that as a prosecutor money laundering is
really the movement of money in essence
from the left hand to the right hand but
going through a series of transactions
so that we don't know where it came from
in the United States for example if you
deposit ten thousand dollars or more it
then gets recorded you have to fill out
a form so if you go around depositing
nine thousand dollars in ten banks you
are money laundering what happens in men
affording gates is that you're looking
at financial institutions and financial
criminals so they wanted to hide the
left hand that they were being paid by
the Ukraine to lobby members of Congress
and to get good things for the
pro-russia faction in the Ukraine so you
have to structure or transfer or layer
this money by putting it through a
series of transactions in multiple
financial institutions so it comes out
over here so what did they do they set
up dummy companies or what we call shell
corporations and when the money goes
into there and then it gets confused and
then it comes out and what did they do
with it well we know according to the
indictment that man Ford winds up with
having payments for mortgages for
clothing that's actually my favorite
$849,000
it's not illegal to have an offshore
entity but it's absolutely not taxes on
it correct so why didn't they want to
register as a lobbyist porn for a
foreign compliment well that's actually
a very good question because that would
have made it simple apparently many
lobbyists in Washington don't go through
this registration a fara is what we call
it for an agent Registration Act
prosecution is very rare indeed but the
reality is if they had simply registered
their problem was they'd have to account
for all the money and they'd have to pay
the taxes okay one of the most
intriguing things happen is with george
papadapolis this young campaign staffer
was arrested July 27th and has been
according to this document released last
night a sealed court document he has
been a proactive cooperator willing to
cooperate with the government what does
that likely mean he may have been doing
in the past three months well one of the
things that we look at when you decide
to plead guilty and you've cooperated
are you a past cooperator that is you've
told the government everything you
already did
or are you a quote/unquote proactive
cooperator meaning in essence you're
working for the government working how
you're working to work down your
sentence so what might you do you might
exchange emails with people text with
people talk to people have phone calls
with people you can write we're a wider
government so do any of these charges
does the President of the United States
have any reason to be concerned about
the charges that we're hearing now well
personally I think he probably does have
concerns not only for himself but his
administration but when it comes to
legally the manna for gates indictment
on its face read the indictment all 31
pages has nothing to do with President
Trump or the campaign but the obvious
thing that the lawyers are saying and
that mob Muller would say is does the
president have anything to worry about
well perhaps not yet well here's one
reason may worry and I asked Paula Reid
to check this for me this morning and
she wrote back the docket which shows
that there are four sealed indictments
filed Friday with numbers between the
indictments that we learned about
yesterday so those numbers do suggest
that there are likely other people who
are
by the special counsel that we don't yet
know about just like the Papadopoulos
key well that's why Papadopoulos is so
much more alarming because one of the
things that we know is if you see a one
indictment and you've got one guy
working for you there are others the
reasons I might ought to be concerned is
this is a very aggressive effort very
aggressive investigation and it wouldn't
is what happened yesterday
he is relentless he is dogged and he is
ethical Bob Muller will not rest at the
same time if he doesn't find it he will
say he didn't find it thank you
interesting name Papadopoulos is
something that we're all learning to say
over and over again Thank You Ricky
Kleeman always good to have you at the
table